oh baby oh baby we're back humans it's
your turn jacob it's your turn part two
let's go the controller just so you guys
know we uh that we know the webcam was
skipping the first one we fixed it we
fixed it hopefully
i fixed it
i was an assistant editor for six years
okay
solving problems oh you might get to
fight margaret i might get to fight
margaret [ __ ] jacob you're not even
gonna die this time i died like 14 times
last time i didn't even kill anything
so for reference jacob did run a little
bit away from the shrine where we would
have resurrected yeah i think he was
just walking he was getting the controls
i think it actually did load me back
here did it yeah oh it loaded me at this
thing yeah a little stacked oh and not
at the grace not in the race interesting
all right should i try it fascinating
sneak into this camp you want you think
do you try and take them out try to do
no horn are those like
[ __ ] wallabies they're little they
look like little uh jumping rats
little marsupials of some sort
all right i'm going to say jumping rats
jumping rats i mean that's kind of what
australian jumping rats that's the
aussie jumping rat right there
it'll eat your [ __ ] children i wonder
if there are only certain dudes that
have horns
and there's a way to signify it like
there's only one
there's only one horn i believe so i
can't
i wonder if the it is his role he lives
and dies by the whole he is
there's the guy that is going to see me
if i go out there
i could probably take it
yeah if you kill them each other
facing each other
[Music]
oh i want to see also if two-handed
uh backstab
you're gonna need to do this pretty
quick
because in bloodborne the posts do the
same damage whether you're transformed
or not
because you're actually like using your
fist it's so nice to watch a real gamer
play this oh my god
somebody doesn't die every 10 seconds
you know what i'm saying
okay
it's just jokes bro we also have the
advantage of having watched youth
yeah i've learned i've learned a lot no
i'm not actually butt hurt
yeah yeah he's carrying
okay
i thought he pulled it out of his ass
that's why i keep my mom
yeah but there's the patrols coming i'm
gonna let horn guy come back i'm gonna
kill horn guy yeah that's good
do you remember adam films you might be
too
it was like this a weird little orange
atom
uh
and it was like pre youtube
atom yeah like a molecule
um
it was pre youtube pre like even quick
time i think it used real player and it
was they hosted a bunch of short films
and music videos yeah i think so
um i remember
there was a band called butt trumpet
i don't love that we just have an axe
that's like very boring well we haven't
found any weapons or anything you have
not that's why i mean
cool
i wonder what the equipment load i'm
sorry that's
um the guy in uh resident evil village
oh
oh yeah
big old belly button boy yeah i love him
oh
baby speak of the devil
let's get now let's get in the bush and
see if we can hold this thing
okay what do we got
it's so awesome oh oh but but
put it on yeah you need two hand it
oh nope nope you can't even touch it
wait hold on uh go back up to and press
x
or press it again well crafted straight
press y
where's it oh you don't have enough text
yeah so
it looks like this the same way it works
um to two-hand you still need
the dex requirement yeah and then with
oh that was your two-handed sword
what was that two-handed no no uh if
your strength isn't high enough yeah
you'll be able to two hand a weapon but
not single yeah only two oh yeah i think
it's yeah it's like that yeah at least
in dark souls it's two-thirds
so like if the strength requirement is
30 and you have 20 then you can two-hand
it but you always need the dex
requirement
yeah we haven't leveled up yet
we don't even know a horse
i know
i want to kill the guy first before i do
my flower picking i don't want to mix
the two activities
i respect that so the one horn guys had
a real like real thing you have one horn
yeah
um i don't know that that's a rule but i
remember it from the area
um my guess would be that it operates
the same way most games
but you could probably scope it out
what was it
oh the god of war
there's something i was playing recently
where
oh [ __ ] they had a crank
is that dragon light too
oh yeah it was like they have like a
little thing and it goes like
that yeah
at the gates
here we go more treasure
a flame
oh
let's have a look yeah skip out the
flail
axe is such a boring weapon son of a
[ __ ] damn it
and it's dex again yeah all right well
we got these for later yeah we need to
go find that lady
i'm pretty sure she's
like no she's at that that restaurant a
lot of guys maybe that's just in the
network yeah yeah
they're still c4 yeah after you're
outside
i was a wolf too oh yeah the dogs there
are two of them i think oh you know we
could do at that grace it'll guide you
to where you're supposed to go yeah
that's probably where it's pointing it's
probably pointing to her
crandall's on the
case you can trust crandall
they could hear about that
yeah she really just needed something
there's one thing that always she's
great something that always gets me is
dogs and from soft candy yeah they're
[ __ ] up it's just the noises they make
still breaks my heart
a lot of them when the you can't see
them
they'll teleport yeah like i think it's
a dark souls 3 yeah yeah so they'll stay
on your ass basically yeah i think it's
in dark souls 3 where they can literally
teleport
above you holy [ __ ] so you'll be running
and then suddenly a little skeleton dog
will appear above your head and fall on
you wow
i wonder if there is some significant
meaning to where the butterflies are
oh yeah look at that i can't wait to
watch a whole video about that oh yeah
watchy now has like a decades worth of
new content yeah i bet every time a new
game comes out from fromsoft he's like
great let's go
yeah i wonder
we should look at sakura and see
but sakura doesn't even have as much
lore it seems like this is also
different because um it wasn't uh
localized by frog nation so it's like
even the english version it's very
different really i believe
okay nerd um thank you two dots one
stone
nice nice
whoa
all right last crandall oh everybody's
coming though no no not that one guy
oh [ __ ]
oh they got big-ass hammers oh they're
locked
oh yeah i think they are just like
hammers it's like a mallet yeah
oh yeah remember you have the the block
counter too yeah
that guy looked like he kind of got
off balance when you block
oh yeah i see that oh repost okay i
didn't want to do it with this guy right
on it
see that i think that worry
[Applause]
you're doing great you're doing great
you an aggressive player john
and it's your fault yes interesting
because i feel like i play like jacob
which is very cautious
i mean you saw me playing return all
right yeah but i mean i've also played
see you play dark souls and you're great
that's just because i've learned all the
move sets
still and i and i think it gives me a
false like almost like a
hubris
where i'm like oh i can do this yeah and
then i actually get [ __ ]
i did use all my flasks yeah but we can
go to the bracing yeah
they'll respond all right
i love when the frames fast forward back
up
sometimes it does it on facetime video
and catches somebody up it's great okay
we didn't alert
big guy yet though wait big guy yeah
there's like a commander yeah
oh jacob can you try the two-handed
sneaker you see that's like yeah
you see my little was it it was a yr one
that's what it was yeah there is a
staircase down
you're right okay i'm gonna let the uh
guy walk by and then i'm gonna take out
let's go right this guy and i think oh
no there's two of them left [ __ ]
so where's big boy then that's him there
he is on patrol right you could probably
get the guy on a run yeah
i think i'll do just that sorry for
backseat gaming
yep does more or no it doesn't 169 is
the same
cool that's good enough
where'd the
you probably heard yeah he might be
investing in there you are
nice jacob oh that's dope dude yeah
that's cool okay how'd you do that that
was the power that's just block and then
attack and it sounded almost like
if you had an attack a second time he
was like falling down into a riposte
yeah
i just have to go up and actually do the
attack i'm nervous
okay
oh he's beefy
oh look how cool he is
look out he gives that frame attack yeah
spears is the worst i know it's hard to
nice
my favorite thing in mordow was to be a
spear guy
and just whenever
people were having an honorable duel i
just run up and like stab him in the
stem of the lake yeah
you're out of blossom yeah
i'm out of bone darts too
this guy's going to kill me no he's not
you got this
uh are those your um
oh yeah
ah that's fine all right this guy's
tough
oh i tried
oh i got a thousand rooms though we're
gonna have to go get them
uh oh that's how you choose so you can
go to that race see i
when we were doing the network test i
didn't know what that marina thing was
so i kept choosing the grace
and then having to run like three times
as far yeah
well i can get my
get my rooms down the hill and then just
move on
yeah i mean you could try it wait go to
the grace real quick if you haven't
singing yeah okay so it wants us to go
there is that leading us to the boss
probably yes i would guess that it's
leading you to the closest point of
interest okay i'm gonna go get my uh my
runes i think it's the way that it's
like trying to do linear structure then
bounce
i was gonna feel like it would guide us
to the lady
maybe she is up there yeah or she's like
after you beat the boss or some [ __ ] um
that is uh
after you maybe after you encounter yeah
the boss yeah like with bloodborne
i guess that's wisdom
look at me nitpicking
all right i'm just gonna run and get my
uh
rude to get out whatever you want
we got a couple of weapons out of this
bye
i see him i see him
i wonder how long they'll chase you for
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
are they still chasing you we're fine
no they stop nice that's actually cool
because there was a little key on my
face
but i think the big boy yeah the big boy
whoa they all put their swords away at
the same time
you cannot stop crandall that guy can
except for this one nobody stops
crandall
i want to know what was down in the
staircase also i could do it
randall cosplay
yeah just take your hair and put it
under your nose
cut
would you ever do like a bob haircut
like crandall
maybe but um somebody when i was a kid
who said you could come back here one
short haircut away from being a lesbian
so i've always tried having long hair
[Laughter]
so i'm like
with my hair this guy didn't get the
memo
all right well there's this you just
would hate to be a lesbian so
yeah
i wonder how much we need to level up
men's pants and men's shoes just you
know i'm gonna dial it in a bit
oh did he go black the first time yeah
oh
why did that just happen
because we rested
oh you just had to rest yeah
her and the blue lady have like the same
eye wound but reversed
so they're like mirror images of each
other interesting
get out your steam she's got the cool
tat
is she [ __ ] cute though
because my chair is shorter than yours i
look very small you do
and i'm closer too that's true
we should both be close then a lot of
them will just be like a little child in
the middle
oh my god
that looks ridiculous
and aid
to the tarnishing
but you
stop calling me out for having no
[ __ ]
you don't have [ __ ] either i see you
haven't gotten laid yet
so my girlfriend do you think if you
rest at a grace she'll appear when it
fades back in
or
because
interesting question do you have to
level through her
not sure
i think so
and i think yes but based on that she's
offering to be amazing
oh yeah for sure we're looking right
apart
your maiden and to go with you right so
my guess is yes she probably appears
apparently you waited a second john
another matter more that's how i change
topics
did you pick up the
groceries
[Music]
just panic when you make a lot of noise
you just you just want to talk
yeah oh torrent chose us
i don't even know he already chose me i
got a respect for myself
all right
dialogue that i skipped over and over
yeah baby
do uh decks up to ten for
this is all stuff all leveling up
memorizing spells oh you could pass time
here too what
maybe because there's thursday night i
know at least one there's this bridge
yeah there's this bridge that at night
like a boss night shows
all right so it's got a question down
it's the whistle right
down is
yeah it's it's oh it's an item you equip
correct
oh okay
oh so i have to stop yeah
you get rid of those knives now these
bone darts
those are crossbow balls yeah okay
and then equip that greatsword dog yes
farewell axe yes
it's stronger too finally cool oh yeah
[Music]
stronger oh and what's its uh stamp is
it special so if you two-handed
and and uh hold l2
oh okay so two-handed l2 then r2
whoa there you go cool cool can i use
some red focus
yes
dude what the [ __ ] it's beautiful so
it's kind of like the weapon arts and
dark souls 3. yeah cool
oh that's weird it uses it even if you
don't do the follow up so you got to
commit yeah let's rest again
[Laughter]
so let's
see okay yes you can just level up from
the bonfire
that's like one of the things that i
wish was in every souls games but it's
only
in dark souls
but you don't want to go to like a whole
island where we
level up go through two loading screens
just a level
you could also go back through and see
if you want to fight that camp
with the sword what would this one yeah
why not look at let's see try it out do
some swinging
i just don't know how you take l1 what
about l1 oh you're right oh awesome
creamy framing framing so intuitive
cradles backwards
oh yeah grinding
so majestic
hi
yeah
oh a trumpet boy doesn't really matter
now doesn't it no you'd be like [ __ ] i
mean if i run into a wall of them
they'll totally kill the [ __ ] out of me
yeah but
how could
it does make it a very different game
yeah oh yeah
oh boy
nice
oh i forgot to turn off the motion blur
oh
yeah they can kill you steve yeah
it's okay oops
i want to see how this great sword does
yeah okay
all the frames
ah [ __ ]
a little bit slower
but worth it yeah
right
just go through here full speed my
allergies
tallyho
you wanna go fight margaret right here
margaret let's do it all right hello sir
your defense has failed
ha ha
you don't want to loop
they got stuff for me
he just got stolen oh he's got a lot of
friends too yeah where did your friends
come from
let's just get up it's mountain bike
big flowers
oh you can pick them from the horse you
[ __ ] oh that's awesome
look at that fruit
flowers all sorts of goodies
what are you all those skulls
holy [ __ ] that's awesome
oh my gosh should i follow the road
that's like the prettiest thing i've
ever seen in a prom soft game sakura is
beautiful yeah
i don't know the dragon
the dragon fight
yeah it's not like that though
oh smoothies me is that a is that a
human norris
excuse me sir it's a dead guy serious
hello
can't wait to watch a 40-minute video
about that yeah seriously
i keep clicking left stick to sprint
like it's in other video games
that's uh definitely not how it looks i
gotta unequip these dang bones
yeah i probably don't need the dang
bones
oh you should press x on it oh i didn't
even do anything
hey there we go
just wanna see what's over here
are there a bunch of wolves what the
[ __ ]
some kind of rock caterpillar some kind
of
a bead catapult
i made it mad
oh
oh i'm gonna
that's cool i really didn't know what to
expect
we never saw the boss i've seen video of
it where it's like
a golem or what what are the yeah
yeah like a man-made creature yeah
that's made out of stone it's so moves
all robotically yeah
it's so crazy
nuts that's where it was trying to tell
you to go then i guess
old frames
farewell horse
yep
oh another vendor
everyone who came with
me they crossed the sea for me they
fought i didn't ask let me guess for you
a nurse she's just oh she hit me
oh
yeah stuck to the sword like william
wallace okay
taken and stuck oh the guy yeah
if you're grafted by the spider
you become a chrysalid
i didn't know that
it is
[Laughter]
yeah was it nvidia ansel or whatever it
is not sure also
cool that'd be awesome
that's the greats
i would guess from
how many souls we get um
you just press like oh
might as well get my health back since
we didn't really fought anything up here
how about we got oh there were just
enough what are we thinking strength
strength get some swinging strength up
to like 25 or something
else
why is that strap
uh so your weapon do big doo doo big
damage also you might have some souls to
pop
i probably have enough for another level
up at this point oh no you said two
little boys
what is that increases
wow okay
yes we have two of them yeah
oh
baby about to get dunked on dude
increasing not replenished by floss oh
that's
yeah so
that's the there are two up upgrade
items um yeah increase amounts and then
increase the efficacy let me see if
there's like a just in case there's an
anvil in here since we found more
smithing stones but probably not because
[Music]
we did find more spoofing stones we
found one more
oh then i think we could level
how about we pop back over to uh well
that's right we could fast trap did we
try dropping the frames to help sorry
dropping the equality to help with the
frame rate we did not give that a try
okay let's see map
so we found the map so we can actually
see things now
so there's just nothing until you find a
map yeah where was that is that here
stretchabella is where santa is oh and
there there was also the dungeon or the
stairs in the camp yeah very curious i
said go check that out check out the
stairs okay
you can't go you're the pilot okay it's
up to you this way tarnished
may i i'll see if i can sneak into the
stairs yeah we might not have enough
souls
yeah but we do have enough smithing
stones okay so we'll be back yes we will
how many oh wait oh yeah the pippity
poppies give you like 200 each yeah
which ones were those a little
how many does it give you what does it
say
you selected
let's use them both
you got enough
perfect you got 20 extra
oh [ __ ]
plus one baby
oh my god and the next one's four
all right i'm sure we'll be finding lots
of smithing stones oh yeah
how's it swing when i'm doing it again
oh pretty fast yeah that's actually
pretty funny i might claymore i might
stay like that because it swings oh yeah
yeah yeah
oh yeah then if you find another great
sword
uh they've added power stancing from
dark souls too so you can it's basically
like oh specific move sets for dual
wielding i cannot know what dog souls
oh is this kind of like frampton
the river is francis sexy
that's what i look like when i wake up
in the morning
with this mane yeah i think it's a plug
i think it's a cloak yeah that's your
hair yeah pretty much
oh
this is for calling like animal like
spirits to go fight with me
i'll go into the camp
with my new friends
oh
briefly
okay so this is like when you're solo
yeah
is the bell not for summoning co-op
people i assumed about i think that's
what the fingers the fingers
[Music]
oh
baby
so i can't do that here this is
progressing pretty quickly
yeah i think it's giving us all you want
to know why
because there's so much [ __ ] packed into
this game
how would you [ __ ] know
i just do
okay so i'm gonna go back to uh
can you just teleport from the map yeah
at any time you want uh-huh
during a bus fight but
oh you probably can yeah
something i do in a lot of games with
fast traveling is i try to like do it as
little as possible yeah
especially you always get bored
eventually yeah like if i do it like
i'll do it out of convenience like oh i
forgot to go like upgrade something yeah
yeah and i'll do that but if i'm like
just exploring yeah or if it's between
two points that i've already traversed
yeah
you know the land yes i've cleared it
oh
getting ready
oh strong
crandall strong man strong
cradle smart too
yay twofers
looks like oh
crazy so strong what's that
herba
hey
[Music]
my ass already hurts oh you get that
cushion back there
we'll do it in between recordings that
make sense my ass is okay
that horn guy that might have been more
good
it's a humor guy
it's like it's like a pickaxe combined
with a hound yeah a matic baby
there's like i said too many words for
hammer
oh okay [ __ ] boy
oh yeah oh
oh cool
it's you
they're glitched help me wolves help me
attack can they get hit they must be
yeah they'll probably disappear soon oh
they agree on them too yeah
yeah i wonder how long they last
i'll try to get the backstab
all right now and look at that stamina
you got like six hits in yeah oh
carrying spears
yeah it's always a bad time
get them wolves get them wolves
oh that's awesome
dude
i like it oh i love them
go kill more
oh they killed one of their own
oh hush all right where's that big guy
he probably had some some goodies
there you are oh he didn't did you not
[ __ ] you just had souls
oh good boy what happened to your
brother you accidentally hit them oh
should i try
oh look you can see their health over
there yeah whoa
why don't they last until they die
yeah i think so
based on the fact that you can see it in
the evil eyeliner
i think i thought maybe it would be time
look i think it was i used all of my
focus though
so
what have we here
what if it's going to be like
oh it's just treasure oh it's a mimic oh
i
swear a [ __ ] mimic down here okay
thank god
we both like
all the words these ashes of watergrain
your own men's new skills oh yeah so the
okay so that stamp or whatever it's
called
the thing you have yet i got a new steam
oh wait okay oh it's a stomp store
they're all
stmps
all right we went down in the basement
yeah we did it
it was worth it all right i'm going to
get back in the whole camp it was
[ __ ] easy yeah i got my friends now
yeah are they going to tell them
oh let's find out
oh they won't but that is traumatized
no they're gone
all right i'll rest to get my uh focus
back
just interesting that with fast
traveling you don't automatically level
up again more strength mm-hmm all right
now that's what i'm talking about that's
exactly what i would do when i play it
oh hi
i stopped him
oh look at her little face like i heard
you like dogs
i would be lone wolf
she looks so happy
oh wait i want to see what's ashes of
war
those are your that's my stomp stamps
yeah
storm stop
might as well
oh oh wait what is it so
it doesn't change oh
okay it's changing it to a quality grade
which i guess increases the scaling sort
of not enough for not enough to switch
to it but it's still
more yeah yeah it's a better d
shall we
i guess let's just let's do it ignoring
my shield and then try two-handing does
it say storm stop now oops
i'll do that
yep
let's check that out
wait no that seems wrong just hold on
one try
oh
it probably is it like probably
knocks people off their feet or
something that seems handy all right
spectral steed come forth
i love it
oh i love that you can see
them on their seeds yeah oh speaking of
ha ha
oh god oh my
god oh ninjas holy [ __ ] no chess
shortstop storm oh you're right yeah
have we seen any means to um
your steed like
previously stamina it looks like it's
staggered but
hmm
possibly yeah
it probably breaks uh like attacks and
stuff yeah depending on their poise
oh a shield of cool shield
oh clothes
nice
and a mushroom
you love those
oh
i tried to bury yeah every time i try to
parry
no no no no no no no you put that
crossbow away
point like
[Music]
[Music]
that's awesome
that's good so that you don't have to
constantly be going back again open one
game they have to change but also it
incentivizes you to get into fights
there's ripping off doom totally yeah
oh better physical
weighs a little bit more but yeah i
wonder what looks wait do you have mid
roll now
nope it's not a fast roll one it might
be like ds3 where mid roll is negligible
i got some clothes though
but you look less hot let's see they do
that
it looks dumpy super dumpy
oh actually that's
your bottle buddy yeah
don't do enough skirt yeah you can see
my thighs still yeah that's we'll take
that we'll take it it's a little twirl
now
very muscular it looks perfect
oh no
okay oh the wolves are gone oh look
there's [ __ ] night bats or something
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah it does holding b make you go first
yeah i keep cleaning that thing
i keep doing on two because it's c3 i
think so i'm gonna try and sprint
anything else oh oh get him let's go
get him
a little dumb beetle
oh another new thing
so are those our lizards in this cave
yeah there's a poop poop bugs bugs
that's like keep on loot pigs
oh loot pig
you around
i have your shields now
it's just up there any he's on the
bridge oh he's got friends
noise
he really just came up
oh
yeah
oh yes
oh sorry
don't touch me puff
these are a smooch heavier
dogs often don't get peds oh boy facial
hair
she likes it so rubbery
between the eyes there's our middle
there she really does there's a big thud
with the mid roll when you do it is that
oh that's bad that might be a fat roll
it might be fat rolling yeah the thumb's
generally fat i'm taking the pants off
nice
so you should women can't wear pants was
it above 70
uh does it show a percentage on this one
it doesn't oh
medium load oh so that's convenient so
this is just yeah in dark souls 3 the
difference between like fast and
mid-roll
oh [ __ ] you oh my god you [ __ ]
which one did it come from oh up there
there's probably a ballista yeah
oh oh they all they're lying in wait oh
they're stealthing get those eagles this
is an ambush
[ __ ]
oh man
they it's probably not in this but what
if there was a you could parry
uh
projectiles and bag that would be
amazing
i see you
it's like maybe i could get one more off
yeah
oh
i broke this thing nice
stance
posture damage who
was shooting the things that was the guy
i killed was it oh the like big yeah
there's the ballista there i think
behind the bush yeah oh yeah
yeah can
oh yeah excuse me oh look at that damage
yeah
hey um
i love that they
still let you spin around yeah it just
feels so good all right let's see
god damn i say that that's the whole
gameplay mechanic they gotta add in well
they did that in dark souls too
yeah yeah
all right
that's how you cheese uh that i don't
like this hallway pursuer this hallway
look doesn't look like it doesn't
maybe touch some graces touch some grace
all right we level up more streaks
it seems like you have more than enough
endurance
yeah yeah i'm really not using that much
stamina i did take a couple hits though
where it took almost oh yeah blocking it
seems like stamina
gets [ __ ] more but attacking it seems
like less wild street
i see what it looks like
turns it into a heavy gray does it
remove
like cost are they like consumables this
oh and it uploads your strength scaling
yeah it gets really out of there oh yeah
and it gets rid of dexterity
it got rid of deck scaling yeah no deck
scaling oh it was a minus
one
oh it is going yeah
yeah
it's like
lisa doing the
i'm just going to do this and if you get
in my way
are you cool
yeah how do you
i think it's a sorcerer roger just roger
roger rodgers bloody roger
i know this bridge roger
i'd like to just summon him and watch
him get [ __ ] over if you want sure
because we've already beaten him yeah
it's true that's true come forth
cooperator
like see how efficient the npc summits
are
come here hey roja hello roger
he has like one of those police batons
oh god excuse me like the perpendicular
handle just being in this location again
makes me uneasy
you did it last time
how much you want to bet that there's
like a
another phase yeah
to make it different that would be blame
dude he's so cool he is
gonna hit me with that big stick
oh my god what if you could jump
that high but your bones were the same
density
all right maggie let's go
i don't remember those straps oh it was
blocking it and then there was that big
hammer thing
all right let's see what roger
go roger
oh all right you doing great bud
you're doing great
you're doing very little damage so good
he's alive
right he's a distraction if anything
yeah that's true
i gotta hit his little butt now
oh
he remembered me
i do have more flasks than i did last
time that's true but we don't have any
uh
yeah roger's almost dead yeah nothing
hey he just caused a cool spell that's
true
oh
oh oh we're close
let's do that get out of here roger
roger now you're attacking he's got a
rapier yeah
oh that's too early
i know that wow cool roger you're dead
you're [ __ ] dead
well thanks for trying buddy
didn't he throw more knives
i think later he'll throw away more okay
and then also he'll bust out a sword
oh you little [ __ ]
quite large [ __ ] he's pretty big
i want to get away from that edge
however there was that period during the
during the network test we were trying
to pay them into falling off yeah
like the developers hadn't thought of
that yeah but it's because you want a
time limit there we go
like we were trying to beat him like up
to the closing minute
yeah oh [ __ ] we are doing
do you think it's
going to grind
i mean not grind just explore the rest
of the first area
i mean we can jake can totally do it oh
it's this far that [ __ ] me up
that combo yeah
we are doing a lot less damage than we
thought him i mean you can totally do it
it'll just take it do it some patience
as well
we never found that little automaton
little the pop boy
well him yes
but also the [ __ ]
stone dog
boss
well i know it was in the network test
oh was it yeah
curious no rogers this time
it's a shame he was so
helpful i don't know if we could do it
he's made us feel better about ourselves
we just look cool though yeah we had a
little breath
go get my rooms
yeah 100 of them
oh you're doing more yeah it's because
of roger i think is making it harder
yeah yeah it scales doesn't it when you
have uh oh
it does
yeah all of them is crusty i can't wait
for the rand monster the way they
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you're biting your teeth yeah is
something to fight your own teeth yeah
okay
oh yeah remember that your shield is 100
block by the way
right
whoa
oh [ __ ]
that's a pretty
oh good oh you could have summoned your
wolves
all right i got my focus back maybe a
distraction actually yeah
all right should i do it one more time
okay okay
yeah
yeah i'll spend the rest of this uh
attempt just fighting margaret
margaret
you got that yeah good call with the
wolves yeah do we want to order food
anytime or should we just heat up that
chinese that's what i was going to say
get through
i'll save the uh i'll save the wolves
for the hard part i'm going to eat the
chinese for lunch tomorrow
how many food options it's true
what do you guys think leave a comment
down below what should we eat we'll be
waiting for the next four days
please
oh it's that damn night so fast yeah
oh yeah okay so that's that is a knife
so it does come
the sword is the one i think what we
figured out was you could block most
everything but the sword all you had to
do was just get your distance yeah
it's just a matter of not being there
when the sword happens
oh i did
[Music]
it's like a growth it's pretty gross
yeah it fully looks like
yeah okay it's hammer time
[Music]
damn you're [ __ ] them up yeah that
was good
oh [ __ ]
here's the sword there's the combo that
i'm scared of he's [ __ ] the wolves up
though
[Music]
we watched that happen to himself
it's a sword
again
probably got two more tries and that was
only three minutes yeah i mean
when these fights go well they go fast
yeah it's true
also when they go bad they go fast yeah
that's true
yeah i think not having roger is very
helpful
it's a
burden
to all of us what about his nice hate
you are using your block
yeah okay
i was gonna say two hands but
it's a good fail safe sometimes yeah
that's so cool that they brought back
being able to parry wall block yeah
okay the knife didn't do that much
damage luckily whenever i miss it
all right
don't look chicken
i want you so bad right above wild
straight oh yeah look at that
maybe it's like you can summon it's the
same color
yeah probably
oh
all right here we go
i think i'm gonna save the wolves a
little longer yeah oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] okay shut up the wolves show the
wolves
the delays
oh that's a sword
oh
no no no no
wolves
whoops
help help
that was a very sloppy attempt
damn i was doing some big fuck-ups yeah
all right all right what happens
you got this you got this
getting that nice and sweaty yeah what
are you planning to do alana well i was
going to leave and explore
good call
i'll keep finding some stuff that no
one's seen before yeah okay i'm banging
my head against this there's the thing i
got stuck on because isn't it
the network test just had invisible
walls or not invisible walls just like
plow walls
so there are
you could just go other directions
like this isn't you're not bottlenecked
to fight market before you can see like
another place
i think he might be a little bit
but we could still school
i would imagine there are sections
oh yeah yeah but i just mean that
there's more
yeah
and there might be like you know
different biomes or whatever yeah
they got snow can you imagine
nice jacob you're one two three
build one and one and
oh you
i always kind of like when they do those
big attacks because like it's easy it's
really easy to not gonna get fired yeah
oh it's like that one's gonna felt
swinging
that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
oh my god we're just like sprinting away
rather than rolling
oh
yeah
when he busts his sword out yeah
that was
yeah i did
one left
[ __ ] oh no all right
oh wow the day wolves got my way
i got stuck on them
all right wolves are dead
[Laughter]
[Music]
goddamn